there is a new
racial literacy curriculum that's being
taught in lots of schools
that is turning
every subject woke
this is being pushed by pollyanna
incorporated
it's for high school students but it's
not just teaching them
radicalism class it's not just teaching
them okay you've got you've got math
you've got history you've got literature
and you've got social justice
math history literature and progressive
politics no
it's much subtler and and more powerful
than that what these curricula do is
inject wokeness and leftism into every
single subject obviously history we've
been dealing with that for decades
obviously literature we've also been
dealing with that for decades
obviously
sex ed or you know i mean that
comprehensive sex ed is just teaching a
kind of liberal sexual ethic in the
schools that's always been the case
not even just science and but math too
because of a leaked implementation
seminar don't forget this was all
happening behind the scenes
the libs who were pushing this stuff
were trying to hide it from you because
they know that you the parents won't
like it very much but part of one of
their seminars was just leaked because
it was occurring online and it showed
that the libs are now wokening
math class right now go to mdhearing.com
use promo code knowles did you know that
9 out of 10 people still buy hearing
aids from clinics and pay five thousand
dollars or more even though much more
affordable options exist that's why
you've got to check out md hearing aid
md hearing aid is an fda registered
rechargeable hearing aid that costs a
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost md hearing aids volt plus model
costs over eighty percent eight zero
less than clinic hearing aids they bring
clinic level care right to you via
telemedicine from doctors and licensed
hearing professionals md hearing aid was
founded by an ent surgeon who saw how
many of his patients needed hearing aids
but couldn't afford them he made it his
mission to develop a quality hearing aid
that anyone could afford if you forget
to take your hearing aids off in the
shower do not worry the volt plus is
water resistant and up to three feet of
water rechargeable with battery life
that lasts up to 30 hours i
really really love this company
a family member of mine refused to get
hearing aids even though she should have
years ago because of this cost and it
really reduced her quality of life make
sure you go avail yourself of this
opportunity right now get clinic level
care for 80 less with md hearing aid go
to mdhearing.com use promo code knowles
to get their new buy one get 149.99 each
when you buy a pair deal they are adding
a free extra charging case that's a 100
value just for our listeners so head on
over to mdhearing.com
use promo code knowles get their new buy
one get 149.99 each when you buy a pair
deal when you're in math class when i
was in math class
i learned 2 plus 2 equals 4.
i learned
3 times 3 equals 9.
sometimes we go beyond that we do word
problems if john leaves st louis going
55 miles an hour and sally leaves
chicago going 26 miles an hour that kind
of
now what the woke left has done is gone
into even math classes and transformed
even the math curriculum to push a
radical leftist agenda here is the plan
from pollyanna incorporated
so students learn about daca or the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
pro which currently supports over seven
hundred thousand people brought to the
united states as children of adaptation
and so in the first part of this lesson
um students explore the impacts
of both both individually and on our
broader society of the july 2021 court
ruling that daca was unconstitutional
and then in the second part of the
lesson students imagine that they are
helping to plan a protest in support of
daca and they need to determine how to
maximize attendance given a variety of
outreach options and constraints
um this is this is going to help
students think about math you see if if
pablo pays the criminal cartel ten
thousand dollars to smuggle him and his
friends into the united states and juan
sells his sister into slavery to the
cartel so that he can get a ride across
the rio grande what is the number of
their criminal gang
ms 13. there it is didn't you just learn
something about math was it that's great
now you're prepared to be become an
engineer someday aren't you aren't you
so glad that the libs woke the math
curriculum not just on daca so they they
transform the math curriculum to to suit
their goals on the immigration policy
then they use the math curriculum to
push a completely false narrative that
cops in the united states have an
epidemic problem of targeting innocent
black men and then lesson eight um
this is a heavy one and we definitely
recommend that teachers prepare their
students and themselves um in advance of
teaching this lesson it's about police
killings of people of color and it uses
data to explore racial
disproportionality among the victims of
police killings and of police use of
force
so students examine real world data to
determine that black and latinx people
are killed by police at rates
proportionate to their overall
representation in the u.s population and
then they examine data that debunk the
misperception that police kill more
black and latinx people because those
people commit more crimes
and then finally they consider what it
would take to eliminate these
disparities
so there are two problems with this
approach to education at least there's
probably more than two problems but the
two major problems are
one
the the woke teachers and the and the
people creating the world curriculum are
filling students heads with things that
are not true
they're filling students heads with a an
understanding of american history and
literature and
and society and politics that is not
true and they do it in every single
class including math that's the first
thing but the second thing that's so
awful about this strategy
is
they are depriving kids of an actual
education
two kids go to math class one goes to
ordinary math class and learns
arithmetic and algebra and trigonometry
and calculus and then another kid goes
to
this woke math class where they learn
that george floyd is a secular saint and
cops are really bad and we need to
abolish the police and also two plus two
equals four which kid regardless of all
the stupid political ideology coming
into the second kid's head which kid is
going to get the better math education
obviously the former
so these libs are like absolute leeches
they're just absolute parasites
not only infecting their host with
diseases but also just sucking them dry
depriving them of nutrients that they
otherwise would get in their education
this is happening in the shadows because
every reasonable person hates it and
objects to it i don't care what part of
the country you're in what race you are
what background you come from
whether you're a republican or a
democrat
obviously all the republicans are going
to hate this stuff but i bet most of the
democrats are going to hate it too
this is radical stuff the evidence of it
of how unpopular it is is that they have
to teach it in the shadows
i'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up stop ring the bell ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications for the michael knowles
show head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe
over there leave a 25 star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you